this is the last day before the Supreme
Court goes on summary says the justices
could rule on several cases this morning
they could also decide whether to
consider the Trump administration's
appeal of a temporary travel ban and we
may hear about the future of Justice
Anthony Kennedy the swing voter on the
High Court is said to be considering
retirement Jan Crawford is at the
Supreme Court Jan good morning well good
morning so Charlie you know that the
last day of the term it's always so
exciting you give these major cases but
this year the court didn't really have
those big blockbusters that has had in
the years passed maybe because they only
had eight justices until Justice Gorsuch
was confirmed in April so that means the
big news today could be whether or not
they decide to add a case for next year
the Trump administration is asking the
justices to reinstate its travel ban of
six majority Muslim nations that's been
blocked in the lower courts now if the
justices agree to hear this case they
could have arguments in October if they
don't those decisions that block the ban
would continue to stay in place Charlie
Jones what about this talk that Justice
Anthony Kennedy the swing vote on the
Supreme Court may retire giving
president from another opportunity to
nominate a Supreme Court justice Oh
Charlie I mean Justice Kennedy I mean he
is widely expected to retire in the next
year or two but the question is when he
is 80 years old he's been considering
retirement but here's the thing he is a
moderate conservative so if he goes
that's going to get President Trump a
massive opportunity to move the court
further to the right for generations and
Democrats would basically be powerless
to stop it that's because they played
all their cards trying to block justice
Neel Gore says she was confirmed to
replace Justice Scalia and that led
Senate Republicans to change the rules
to end filibusters of Supreme Court
nominations but you know Justice Kennedy
I mean he's always a difficult justice
to predict as we have seen but here's an
interesting fact on this day in 1987
justice Lewis Powell retired and you
know who replaced him Justice Anthony
Kennedy
Jan thank you she looks like she's in
her element doesn't she like she doesn't
bun up as she does